hey everyone I'm so excited to be here
I've heard so many great things about
strange loop over the years and it's
just such an honor to get to talk to you
about some of the things I've learned
about security over the years so I'm
gonna be talking about building secure
cultures my slides are online already so
you don't have to take notes there's
lots of Creative Commons Attribution zin
the link in the notes as well as links
to various resources so check them out
also quick content note I am going to
talk about plane crashes but nothing
graphic and like pretty minor so how
they were like investigated and solved
if you're not a fan of plane crashes
just a heads up so me my name Lee
Honeywell I work at slack on the
security response team there I'm
managing it I used to work at Heroku
Microsoft Symantec I paint and I'm
sometimes a cranky feminist on the
internet I laughed a bunch when a me
apologized for being a lawyer yesterday
I was raised by a feral pack of Canadian
lawyers and I think lawyers are really
important for society I think it's
actually security people that need to to
be apologizing like I'm a security
person I'm apologizing to all of you
it's also just partly being Canadian so
sorry that's how you know someone's
Canadian you bump into them and if they
apologize to you they're Canadian so we
get told to move fast and break things
right this is like one of the mantras of
Silicon Valley but then this happens
it's a little hard to see the text here
but this is some guy named Khalil
posting on Mark Zuckerberg wall he tried
to report a security bug to Facebook
through their usually excellent bug
bounty program you know they
misinterpreted the result turned down
the bug he posted on zux wall and and
then we get stuff like this our plate is
a fascinating case study of the state of
security response in the open source
world a researcher at Google
Neel Mehta found the bug went through
various like proper channels to report
it you know and it got like shared with
the Linux distros the major cloud
vendors a few really important sites
when you read through a detailed
timeline of the event you start to see
where the information starts to move
around and there's starting to be like
just enough information
out there that other researchers go
poking and some Finnish researchers
found the same bug and then everyone was
like all the cats out of the bag and the
embargo actually broke so it was
released a Monday morning instead of a
Tuesday but I want to go back even
further this is a map of the world on
July 15 2001 this is the code red worm
it exploited a vulnerability in
microsoft iis that hadn't been patched
about a month previously as bulletin MSO
103 3 and the reason I know those
numbers is that I used to work ten years
later I worked on that team the
Microsoft Security Response Center I
handled security vulnerabilities in
Windows Office SharePoint Skype a number
of others and the the thing that was
pretty cool there we had this whole set
of policies and practices in place where
we could work with external people to
take in security vulnerability
information we had all this telemetry
where if someone was using malware in
the wild and it would cause crashes
there's a great story in the notes I'm
not going to go into in detail that
really I you you would find these bugs
that were being actively exploited it
would show up in telemetry and you'd be
able to reverse engineer what was the
vulnerability that was being that was
being exploited there it was this
methodical ceaseless every second
Tuesday of the month and every once in a
while a second time during the month for
emergency patches process of updating a
billion computers around the world so if
you if you were running Windows in 20
2012 I rebooted your computer and sorry
so in that job I got to work internally
within Microsoft with developers testers
executives PR everybody coordinating
shipping patches and Windows shipping
patches in office and working with the
external researchers who were often
reporting bugs to us and then you know
in the best cases we would take the
lessons learned from those bugs that
were reported to us cycle them back into
the development process and build more
secure software in the future and it's
like we do something pretty similar we
have a bug bounty program where
apparently at
and seventy-seven thousand dollars in
bounties paid out its we've had hundreds
of researchers around the world report
bugs to us but this is the systole and
after the fact kind of thing so it makes
me wonder like what does it mean to
build secure software before you're
shipping it right Bounty's Security
Response all of this stuff is the cat's
already out of the bag your site's
already your sites already owned your
desktop software that you shipped
already has a bug in it what can we do
but before we ship that that code to
make things better so some of the things
that that looks like in a culture in a
in an organization that has a healthy
security culture is you have developers
reaching out to the security team when
they're stuck or unsure about the
implementation of a feature you have
developers finding bugs in each other's
code security bugs during the code
review process you have a enough tooling
testing in place that people feel like
they're protected from small errors or
regressions and one of the big ones one
of the big like organizational smells of
a healthy security culture is you have
people saying like fessing up when they
make a mistake about security reaching
out proactively to say oh hey I pasted
idea tube u.s. cred in the wrong window
and Aflac DM whatever I deleted it I
mean and cycled it already but I just
wanted to let you know also please don't
put your slack your slack tokens on
github makes me really sad has anyone
had a slack token deleted from github
it's been nuked that was posted on
github no okay we nuke them proactively
yes yay excellent
so we proactively go out and and nuke
those tokens what we're talking about
here is complexity right the software
that many of you work on is unimaginably
an unknowable complex with open SSL we
could blame the like weird janky export
regulations stuff that people had to do
regulatory compliance stuff but in any
sufficiently large code base you're
gonna have those weird dark corners
you're gonna make mistakes we're human
we make means we make mistakes you're
gonna introduce security bugs
one model that I like to think about in
thinking about security bugs is and
complex systems it's called the Swiss
cheese model of accident causation was
first proposed by English psychologist
James reason he talks about the latent
hazards in the system the holes in the
cheese and how failure occurs when those
holes line up and and the error is able
to pass through in security and in
testing we call this bug chaining I
first learned about this book this model
from the book the digital dr. hope hype
and harm at the dawn of medicines
computer age which I particularly like
because we're not just at the dawn of
medicines computer age we're really at
the dawn of computer Security's age -
like we're we are all beginners at this
so what can we do about this right like
we have these complex systems they're
error-prone were humans we make errors
any different part of your computer
system can fail so how do we get to this
like solid block of cheese that errors
cannot pass through in thinking about
your system you got your components
you've got your tooling you've got the
humans involved you got your underlying
infrastructure data center cloud
somebody else's computer and each one of
those is going to have holes so all that
we can hope to do is make them smaller
make there be fewer of them and make
sure that they don't line up so here are
some of the things that as individuals
anyone here in the audience can do the
first thing is to go looking as a
developer there's a lot that you can do
as an individual to learn to make your
code better from a security perspective
whether it's reading up on the latest
classes of threat on the OS wiki fuzzing
your code with the adorably named
American fuzzy lop it's named after a
bunny rabbit doing some static analysis
reading some books or getting yourself
some some training and security but
fundamentally though it's a mindset
thing you're putting yourself in the
attackers shoes you're saying if I had
control of this input as I'm thinking
through these data flows what kind of
problems could I cause what shenanigans
could I get into and going from there so
back when Vista was under development
everybody's favorite operating system
the powers that be at my
Soph paid a bunch of external developers
a bunch of external security researchers
to do a full code audit of all of the
new code and they actually ended up
slipping the release of vista because
they've had so many bugs it was it was a
big project but the interesting part of
the story to me is in 2011 i saw a talk
given by one of these testers named
Kristin Padgett her NDA had expired and
she's like I'm gonna tell all I'm gonna
steal all the beans it was great so the
the things that she was able to develop
in doing this massive massive scale code
audit there was no way that even with
the pretty large crew of security folks
they had they couldn't go through every
single line of code so what they did was
they interviewed teams and they
developed a really strong sense of
security smells so secure the security
smells that she talks about were things
like people's body language whether they
seemed calm or anxious as they're
talking to security people confidence or
lack of confidence in describing the
functioning of their component and so as
they worked with these different
developers pm's
different folks around the windows
organization they were able to say oh
this is code there there be dragons
there be dragons here we got to dig into
this code and the effectiveness was
shown by just how many bugs they found
so as like a self-awareness thing when
you're writing code paying attention to
that gut feeling paying attention to
that like this this this component is
keeping me up at night not ignoring that
and when you have that feeling asking
for help whether it's from your security
team appear doing some additional
research yourself but following those
hunches following that you know
developing that sense of smell for your
own code and if you reach out for help
within your organization and you get
shot down like that's a pretty useful
signal to maybe not a great one but yeah
so the other thing that I love to tell
people about if they haven't heard about
before is capture the flag so there's
all these hacking tournaments that
people put on and I'll have some links
next but it's basically like jeopardy
style board there's here's the hundred
point reverse engineering challenge
here's the 200 point web web app hacking
challenge and it's a great time
constrained way of learning new security
related skills CTF time org has a great
directory of them to get a team going
all you really need is some form of
chatroom not agnostic to what kind and
in a Google Doc I will note that
security is maybe like ten years behind
the rest of the world when it comes to
like having welcoming environments and
often if like the event has an IRC
channel it'll be kind of foul it's still
worth it to me but heads up and then
beyond just what individual things
people can do I think it's really
important to think about organizational
processes so more stuff I learned at
Microsoft they have this security
development lifecycle it's this
sophisticated hundred-plus procedure
pain compliance thing that people do
despite its complexity there's a lot of
really interesting stuff that people can
learn from it it's all creative
commons-licensed and worth checking out
but it's it's gotten me thinking a lot
like this this is great when your
shipping code when you're shipping
Windows every two years when your
shipping office every two years but it's
less feasible for those of us in the
room who ship code every day or multiple
times a day so the the big thing that my
sort of the MacGuffin I've been chasing
for a couple of years at this point is
is what does this look like when you're
shipping code multiple times every day
so I've been thinking
what's a Minimum Viable SDL going beyond
this big process to what what anyone can
implement in a small organization and
I've come up with these four things a
risk assessment upfront getting people
thinking about what the security posture
of a particular feature they're working
on is doing some threat modeling it
doesn't need to be very formal it just
needs to be I'm thinking through the
data flows of my project upfront a
checklist and there's a ton of different
resources you can use to build those
checklists on your own
whether it's the Mozilla secure coding
checklist the OWASP resources or
Microsoft's own SEL taking the parts
from that that makes sense for you and
then having whatever security tooling is
appropriate for for your codebase
whether it's in your builder CI process
static or dynamic analysis getting those
tools in place so here's what it looks
like
at SLAC we built a self-service SDL that
any team can go in and create an STL
project for a new feature that they're
working on it's been a team effort our
head of product security it's my friend
Ari and he couldn't be here but this is
this is as much his work as it is mine
but you start talking at prot about
process life cycles that small
organizations and people freaked out
also because this is the section where
I'm talking about slack stuff there's a
lot more emojis coming up just heads up
you know your people are like what is
this process I don't want process you're
adding friction you're slowing me down
and so you get this conflict between
security and dev but it doesn't need to
be like that in fact I want it I want it
to be more like this some people may
recognize our bus ads but yeah that's
what I want security to feel like that
is that is it so much to ask so what is
what does that actually look like for us
it's again that initial risk assessment
this is something that the Microsoft
sequel team pioneered and I worked with
them a few years ago and have sort of
carried this with me and that's the
instead of two weeks before you're
shipping or like oh gosh I have to do
all of the security stuff it's getting
people thinking about it at the start of
the project and throughout the process
rather than just on that that last
crunch so we have this little quiz that
you do it's only like six questions long
and various answers will dump you
immediately into high risk or you can
just put yourself into high risk by
saying yes or I'm writing sequel
injection
and so the questions are pretty
straightforward and once you've got that
risk rating it's gonna generate oh it's
gonna go through the component survey so
the component survey allows people to
opt into the the things that they're
doing so if there's no mobile aspect
they uncheck the mobile part of the
checklist so the checklists look like
this super straightforward and you can
uncheck that everything is checked by
default at the top level and you can
check the specific things the sub sub
topics that you need and you can uncheck
the top-level things you don't need but
we encourage people to err on the side
of if you're not sure about it just
leave it checked because you can move it
into the I don't need to do this column
later and like nobody gets mad or
anything so before I get to checklists
this is the part where I talk about
plane crashes so any any fans of the air
crash investigation show in the room
yeah okay I'm glad I'm glad I'm not the
only one so checklists are a huge part
of aviation safety and if you want to
see really the thing that is so great
about the air crash investigation show
is there's like terrible things that
happen and then competent humans show up
and they investigate them and they make
processes so they never happen again and
that's why I like air travel is safer
than any other kind of travel pretty
much so most aviation accidents result
from human error and one of those root
causes is often a failure to comply with
checklists
but these checklists also prevent a ton
of accidents so when we were thinking
about how we were going to design this
process design these checklists we
wanted to learn from the human factors
stuff of aviation safety for like why do
people avoid checklists what could we
adapt from that so my my colleague read
the entire three hundred page report
from the FAA on human factors in the use
and design of checklists and we went
through that and we're like what are the
parts of this that matter to security so
there were a there was like act as some
fundamental stuff of where checklists
fail it's failing to use the checklist
failing to verify the settings visually
being interrupted is a big one so some
of the things that we incorporated into
our own process we're oversight of the
completion of the process from the
security team the security team
being involved and being tagged in at
different parts of the process making
the tasks as simple as possible and I'll
go over this a little bit more but they
they're affirmative statements I'm not
you are yeah they're all affirmative
statements rather than I'm not doing the
wrong thing
I am doing the right thing so and then
we also have the feedback cycle from the
bug bounty when our checklist fail we
usually hear about it pretty quickly
which is nice and if you don't feel like
reading a 300-page FAA document I
definitely recommend Atul Gawande is the
checklist manifesto for a more slightly
less dry version of a lot of the same
information so here's what our checklist
actually look like first of all once
you've gone through that the the
generator thing it starts generating
some Trello boards takes a little while
and then you get a board of all of your
different checklists for for the
different categories of security things
that you need to deal with then there's
a checklist for adding your Trello board
to slack it's not the most elegant part
of the process but here's what some of
the checklist actually look like so
we've got regular expressions and then
we've got alert and warning messages and
the alert and warning messages stuff is
actually taken from the Microsoft STL
because their guidance was really good
on that one and relevant to what we do
and then we can have like a visual
overview of what's been checked off and
what hasn't and most importantly because
you've connected it to slack we have our
nice little STL bot that tells people in
your future Channel
you've connected it to the feature
channel for whatever the project is we
have a lot of feature channels it's like
we have we have a lot of channels in
general like
it's kind of bad and yeah so here you
have a couple of examples of how what
this looks like so we checked off a
checklist item and then Mary's like hey
Josh I don't think we've actually we're
not ready to check that one off can you
leave it unchecked for now and we'll
come back to it or Josh is verifying
with the rest of the team that this
particular item has been correctly
correctly dealt with we've disabled DTV
parsing yep okay I can check that one
off so there's there's that sort of
you're you're bringing the security
stuff to where people have where people
are actually working and the reason this
matters is that it a lot it moves away
from that one poor tester who has to do
the hundred and twenty items' checklist
two weeks before the launch to a
collaborative enterprise to a
collaborative effort of people working
together to make sure that your shipping
secure code and it also means that as
teams are working on their own getting
through a particular set of checklists
if they're if they're ever like not sure
how to do things they just tag us in so
here the team is asking Maria for help
with a particular UX decision that has
an impact on security Marie Maria brings
in hey here's an example of how a third
party does it that that would work well
in this case I think and then the team
is like oh yeah that that totally fits
our purposes and Maria just pops out
doesn't need to be lurking in that
Channel all day and then we're able to
get ongoing feedback about the impact of
this of this process on teams on on the
work that people are doing because we
have the bug bounty because people are
able to just file bugs in the SDL
process itself internally the the rules
are all just JSON files that live in our
github so people can we can accept PRS
often grammar edits from the rest of the
organization and we're able to were able
to to move the the secure development
process quickly not just move our
general software development quickly so
that's what we've done
as an organization but then there's also
the question of like what can what are
what are the cultural factors at work so
there's a number of things in terms of
the way we we we create cultures that
affect the security of the software that
we produce and holding ourselves those
among us who are leaders in our
organizations which I suspect as many of
you holding ourselves accountable for
the cultures that we create and the
impact on security that it has it's
pretty standard like blameless culture
stuff for any fans of Etsy's Coda's
craft blog this quote may be familiar
but operating from the position that
people want to be writing secure code is
like that's the starting point right
people people don't want to be the one
who ships the code that has XSS in it so
we need to be able to figure out what
what do what resources do we need to get
people so that they can ship codes ship
secure code well whether it's time
training or external expertise so
recruits enter social rules security
teams super often guilty of well
honestly all of them but really like
let's talk about feign surprise right
how didn't you know that that would
cause XSS like dog who's heard something
like that from their security team right
it's yeah so if there's one thing that I
tell other security people all the time
I like hold that sign up in their faces
and say like don't don't do that it's
not necessary that that piece of
feigning surprise like it just as as the
rules say it has no social or
educational benefit when people feign
surprise it's to make themselves feel
better and other people feel worse it's
about making other people feel smaller
and that's not how you build a safe
culture that's not how you write secure
software fundamentally writing secure
software requires a level of emotional
safety I've often had the experience of
trying to talk to a security person
feeling kind of like trying to pet that
cat and I say that as a security person
so there's this idea of emotional labor
that it is actually work to give gentle
feedback to be kind in the feedback that
you're giving to other people it is also
emotional labor to be receiving feedback
to be open to hearing that maybe your
baby is ugly and but this isn't this
isn't just like this isn't just pie in
the sky like let's let's all get along
and write secure software it's actually
supported by some of the social science
research into code quality and when it
comes down to it writing secure code is
writing quality code and writing quality
code is writing secure code so if we are
kind in the feedback that we give we are
building a culture where it is safe to
say I don't know what I'm doing here and
when people are able to say I don't know
what I'm doing they get help and then
the code that they write is better and
that includes security yeah nobody likes
being nobody likes their baby being
called ugly but we need to establish to
re-establish that trust as security
people because people need to be able to
hear if their baby's car seat isn't
plugged in or the seat belt is frayed as
otherwise disaster so being able to
create a culture where you don't get
torn down for saying I don't know how to
prevent XSS in this this particular code
path there's there's a lot of work to be
done on the security side of things to
rebuild that trust so coming back to the
digital doctor I really like this quote
because it cuts to the core of why we
need to be able to have trust in each
other to do security we need to be able
to talk compassionately about the ugly
parts of our code if we have any hope
whatsoever of it being secure and I
talked a lot faster than I expected but
again there are slides available and
yeah thank you very much for listening
to me talk about secure software
you